Can you spot the major differences
between Avatar 1 and 2 because we can't
okay unless you're talking about the
tech that we can talk about we can't
talk about the Recycled plot okay from
milestones in technology to breathing
underwater Avatar 2 quite literally took
the series to a new epic level one of
the harder to miss differences in the
way of water is the fact that it is
underwater this change was more
noticeable for the cast since they had
to act on set all day in water tanks put
us in a tank and do scenes that we have
enough trouble with on dry land and now
they don't move no oxygen we just hope
the director James Cameron takes a safer
approach if they do in fact move to a
more volcanic environment so it seems
like James wanted to take the franchise
down a big turn when shifting towards a
more Family Central story since it is 15
years after the events of the first one
we think it makes a lot of sense to just
kick off the rest of the Avatar series
with a family in the first one it says
you know you've got to find something
worth fighting for now he's found it
more with his own family the camera Guru
pavala chatel innovated 3D technology
just for Avatar 2 Avatar one brought 3D
back to the big screen but now the team
had to somehow capture 3D footage
underwater the solution simple bring
achatel and have him develop deepex 3D
his job was to make it more efficient to
capture this footage underwater now you
know you've got a big movie franchise
when a brand new software is created for
your movie The CGI company WETA FX
actually developed this software that
allows Cameron to capture more accurate
performances from his actors on water
and land and you know what you'd need a
whole lot of to do that money which
we'll Circle back to in a bit unlike
Avatar one Avatar 2 was carefully
crafted at the same time the rest of the
series of films were written this was
done to make sure each film could stand
on its own yet still act as part of a
franchise and so Cameron gathered a
whole bunch of writers and they created
a decades-long blueprint the original
composer for the first avatar created
this beautiful score but unfortunately
between the first and second project he
passed away and couldn't compose for the
rest of the series but he still was a
bit connected to it his partner Simon
Franklin was there to pick up the pen to
write music inspired by this great
friend and musician and so he'd kept the
same style but of course added a little
something different to the mix alright
so Cameron worked super hard to keep the
same PG rating for The Avatar sequel but
he decided that he was gonna make it
just a bit more family friendly than the
first one and so he felt it was for the
best AKA ticket sales to take out any of
the more sensual scenes between Jake and
natiri because that would attract the
younger audience boo so instead of
filming one at a time we all know James
Cameron is just a little bit nuts so why
not film three movies all at once that
wasn't the original plan before the
success of Avatar but the team decided
it'd be way more efficient to just shoot
close to three films before Avatar 2
even released and like is it just us or
is that an insane amount of shots to put
together in post so because they filmed
three movies all at once they actually
had to have like you know everything
like a whole lot of everything more
props sets actors all the while
Innovation is still happening they're
still innovating the way the films are
being shot we can't even imagine
managing this much for a couple of films
let alone the pressure of making it
entertaining for audiences the producer
John Landau had to explain our sets are
big and we have an incredible design
team that does those Brendan Cowell
who's the captain of the Sea Dragon was
on a 60-foot boat on a motion base and
it was real it was tactile like seven
minutes long and at the same time they
somehow had to move naturally underwater
like seriously can you even picture
yourself doing that like after 30
seconds we'd be scrambling for the
surface they all deserve awards for
being able to act underwater for sure
when Avatar 1 came out it seemed like
there were only 3D and regular viewing
options but since the evolution and how
we watch films has progressed so rapidly
and we're not talking from home we can
now see Avatar 2 in four different ways
we're talking IMAX 3D High frame rate
and regular versions if you're that kind
of person you can literally never get
enough of Avatar no matter how much you
watch it so can you imagine being given
one billion dollars to make a bunch of
films well a lot of filmmakers can't
imagine that however with how successful
the first movie was 20th century Studios
was all in and they decided they should
just put all their trusting Cameron's
films and give him a massive lump sum
budget has that ever happened before all
right let's just be honest here he'll
make at least six times that after these
movies are released anyway honestly
we're kinda relieved that they kept some
of the main characters the same at least
and the big differences were just to the
technology but what did you think about
all the changes let us know in the
comments
[Music]